all right welcome to the show it's my
last uh day in the bunker for a little
bit and there is much to discuss
and you know this this first story i'm
going to talk about there there's sort
of some risk to even
talking about this story because
the issue of uh donald trump and russia
has become so weaponized and so
distorted and so partisan
and toxic and tribal it's become so
disconnected from the actual facts that
we know
that there's a risk to even bringing
this issue up again
but there is news that continues to fill
out the story and our understanding
of what took place before and during the
trump administration and we learned
some important things over the weekend
about coordination between the trump
2016 campaign
and russian intelligence and since we've
covered the story all along
it would be weird if i didn't tell you
that there is
new information and there are some in my
audience i know
who refer to the story as russia gate
and refer to me as a
russia gator conspiracy hoax whatever
whatever the terms now are on the story
but
my my core audience who has been with us
you know at least back to 2017
knows that my position on trump russia
uh
was there will be no personal collusion
found between donald trump and vladimir
putin at a personal level there's not
going to be any smoking gun video of
trump and putin
planning anything with regard to donald
trump's candidacy but
it looks like a duck and it sounds like
a duck and it walks like a duck
something approximating a duck is
probably there and indeed
we had more than a dozen indictments in
the molar probe
there was communication and coordination
between trump and russia including
through wikileaks as an intermediary
paul manafort in touch with russians
regarding polling and the campaign and
on and on
it was never going to remove donald
trump go back to my videos from april of
2017 where i made it clear trump was
never going to be charged
or end up in prison as a result of
whatever it was he did or didn't do with
vladimir putin because
i don't want to say no one believed but
our show
was not saying they will be caught
having done anything but it was likely
all along a combination of trump being
sort of a useful
idiot not even realizing how his mere
candidacy his mere presidency
helps russia's goal of destabilizing
western democracies for their gain
and some of the people around trump were
actually in touch with russians and
coordinating so
okay there's a new report and this is a
treasury department deport
report which now quietly
in 2021 years after the entire fiasco
with trump already gone confirms
that donald trump's 2016 campaign was
sharing information with a russian
intelligence officer
full stop that's the story during the
2016 election russian and ukrainian
political consultant
constantin kilimnik we've mentioned this
name before
was providing russia with so-called
sensitive information on polling
and trump campaign strategy kilimnik
quote sought to promote uh the narrative
that ukraine not russia had interfered
in the 2016 u.s presidential election
in 2018 kilimnik was indicted on
obstruction of justice charges
for his unregistered lobbying work
related to ukraine
but this same treasury report now spells
out
that kilimnik had been coordinating with
donald trump's campaign chairman paul
manafort
during the 2016 election the treasury
report refers to kilimnik
as a russian intelligence officer donald
trump's campaign manager
campaign chairman for a period of time
was coordinating
with a man now regarded as described as
a russian intelligence officer and
manafort
repeatedly shared internal campaign
information
with kilimnik as mother jones writes
manafort passed inside info from the
trump campaign to kilimnik
kilimnik gave it to russian intelligence
which at the time
was mounting a covert attack on the 2016
election
to thwart hillary clinton and help
donald trump that's collusion now
it isn't the cartoonish scenarios that
some dreamed up
trump's secretly meeting with putin
personally but it is trump's campaign
uh chairman scheming with a russian
intelligence officer
as russia was publishing derogatory
information about trump's opponent
hillary clinton and preferred
trump over hillary we don't have to get
all dramatic
we don't have to get hyperbolic they
were working together
that's it it's simple meanwhile at the
same time
kilimnik was trying to use paul manafort
and through him use trump to advance
vladimir putin's interests related to
ukraine this isn't unique
many countries try to do this many of
them just aren't as good
as russia at doing it and many countries
don't have someone
as vulnerable and naive and ignorant
as donald trump and the people that
donald trump put around him and it
really went both ways
so for those who will react to this with
like an okay so what type of approach
imagine for a moment that it was
revealed today for example it meant this
hasn't happened but imagine
imagine we learned today joe biden's
campaign manager
was in regular contact with chinese
intelligence officers throughout the
2020 election including
unreported meetings passing internal
biden data and strategy to chinese
operatives
who by the way were working on a
campaign to hurt donald trump how do you
think
people would be reacting right now fox
news would be calling
for the removal and imprisonment of
treasonous traitor
joe biden period and then also remember
that the mueller report basically said
the same things as the treasury report
that we now have
it used different language but just
before the mueller report was released
donald trump's hatchet man attorney
general william barr
put out that four-page propaganda letter
claiming to summarize what was in the
mueller report but not actually
summarizing it coming up with a
completely different
non-actually empirically based
assessment of what was in the report so
that led to the nationwide bogus
exoneration tour that donald trump went
on and the rest is sort of history so
that's the latest it's not really a
surprise
to anyone who has been paying attention
and
it will be ignored by those who are
convinced there was never anything there
uh but i i think that people who
followed the story
soberly and closely from the beginning
would not be shocked
uh nor nor would we think that it would
be out of line with what was going on
at the time to get this report from the
treasury department
we've talked before about how the
post-trump dr
anthony fauci is sort of a new dr fauci
who both feels that the pandemic is
being managed
more competently and feels that he can
simply stick to medical advice without
having to kind of calculate what he says
from the standpoint of
whether the administration will like it
or won't they like it that's a different
dr fauci than we saw
during the trump administration and dr
fauci was interviewed yesterday on cnn
and went right at one of the most
notable it's not even really a hypocrisy
it's really a contradiction
by the american right-wing on the
pandemic they want everything to be over
but they refuse to do the things that
will accelerate the end of the pandemic
they want to go back to normal but they
couldn't even avoid
bars and big parties for a few months in
2020.
and of course they're saying open
everything now it's time to end
everything from a social perspective but
now they don't want to get vaccinated i
told you last week 43
of republicans uh say they don't want
the vaccine and they don't plan to get
it unless for some reason they
have no choice so dr fauci was asked
about it yesterday on cnn he calls it
like it is he explains that the people
who most claim to want
everything to be over are actually
making it go longer by their opposition
to the vaccine and their other actions
take a look
our new poll this week shows that 43
percent of republicans still don't want
to get the vaccine
how frustrating is this for you dr fauci
you know dana it is quite frustrating
because
the fact that one may not want to get
vaccinated in this case a disturbingly
large proportion
of republicans only actually works
against where they want to be
they want to be able to say these
restrictions that are put on by public
health recommendations
are things that they're very concerned
about we're all concerned about that
we share that concern but the way you
get rid of those restrictions
is to get as many people vaccinated as
quickly
and as expeditiously as possible because
when that happens
for absolutely certain you're going to
see the level of virus in the community
go down and down and down to the point
where you would not have to have
those public health restrictions so it's
almost paradoxical
that on the one hand they want to be
relieved of the restrictions
but on the other hand they don't want to
get vaccinated it just almost doesn't
make any sense
paradoxical is exactly the right word to
apply
to this situation now it's also hopeless
for dr fauci to expect these very people
to go and get the vaccine dr fauci wants
the people
who are against abortion but don't want
easier access to contraception to
realize
that they could end the pandemic sooner
if they got vaccinated and this exists a
ton on the right we are against abortion
no matter what
okay great well let's reduce demand for
abortions to do that we prevent unwanted
pregnancy well what prevents unwanted
pregnancy access to contraception
comprehensive sex ed oh but they're also
against that
what it's the exact same thing dr fauci
said it almost doesn't make any sense
i would remove the word almost it just
doesn't make any sense
and very little we're going to talk
later about this actually
very little of the modern republican
party makes any sense it's not just
their position on ending the pandemic if
you want to talk about
other things that make no sense consider
the big picture on vaccines from these
people
the virus isn't serious it's just like
the flu so everything can stay open
but trump is developing a vaccine which
he deserves credit for
which they're not going to take anyway
but he'd better get the credit for it
even though we don't need it and they
won't take it and the pandemic's not
serious anyway well done hold on a
second
then why is it that trump's a hero for
developing the vaccine
you won't take and don't need and by the
way what is pro-life about their
positions on any of these things they
don't want to get the vaccine
nor wear a mask but they want to end the
pandemic our patience
for this nonsense should be very very
low and i've said this before
and it's maybe a good point to end on
rights come with responsibilities i have
an entire youtube segment about this
that you can find
to just go around demanding rights
absent and completely ignoring the
responsibilities that come with them
is not a recipe for a well-functioning
society and unfortunately we're going to
have to go around them or
through them in order to fix this
situation um
they're not going to work with us and
that's maybe the the worst part of all
of it because
people who are doing the right things
are still going to suffer
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter
deepakman
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
remember that the david pakman show is a
viewer and listener supported program
you can support it by grabbing a
membership at joinpackman.com we do have
i i guess what we're calling good news
regarding the johnson johnson vaccine
dr anthony fauci says that he believes
the u.s is going to resume use of the
johnson and johnson vaccine for
coronavirus by the end of the week maybe
with some kind of warning
or restriction attached you might
remember we covered last tuesday that
regulators said
temporarily pause use of the single dose
johnson and johnson vaccine there were
six cases of rare
brain blood clots all in women age
18 to 48 i i believe as of right now
that one of those women
died this is out of about 7 million
johnson and johnson vaccine doses that
were given
and dr fauci says he's expecting a
decision on that vaccine maybe by this
friday
and that the most likely outcome he
seems confident that there will be a
resumption of the use of that vaccine
you will again remember that this was
within 13 days of receiving the shot
women age 18 to 48 who developed
these symptoms the fda decided to put a
pause
out of quote an abundance of caution and
unfortunately you know this is one of
those things that
what what's tough about it is that it
will
create certainly some additional
anti-vaxx
sentiment and provide uh fuel for the
anti-vaccine crowd
even if it is not um warranted and it's
one of these things where you really
have to think of the numbers big picture
that vaccine has been given
to more than seven million people there
have been six or seven
blood clots reported uh and
one of those people died and when you
first of all when you compare that to
the death rate of getting the virus
itself that's important context to have
and to provide
the other reality is you know if if you
wanted to be
really careful with this and this is i
think what dr
fauci is kind of alluding to or or maybe
what's being considered by regulators
it was all women 18 to 48. what if you
say well maybe
you don't give this vaccine to women 18
to 48.
the other factor and i mentioned this
last week
and there's some early uh suggestions
but it's still being investigated
that there may be um a medicine
interaction
that is common to the individuals that
experience this the six or seven women
that experience the the blood clotting
if it were determined that there's a
specific interaction between a
medication that these women were on and
the vaccine
that would even be further reassuring
you could figure out exactly who it is
that should not receive this vaccine
um and that's something that is
increasingly being looked at
uh there there was a bit of a slowdown
over the weekend
in terms of vaccine doses and in fact
i'm pulling up the numbers myself
although it's not clear that it's
related to the johnson and johnson
um decision if you look at uh the
numbers from over the weekend there was
a bit of a slowdown in the number of
doses given
there are reports that this may be
because of what's called
demand uh slackening a little bit there
was just a little bit of a downturn if
you go back to about april 11th and look
at the last eight days
the average number of doses has gone
down now part of it reasonably would be
because of the j
and j pause but there are reports that
some states states where there's less
interest in the vaccine places like
the example we've been looking at is
mississippi um
there we may actually be at the point
where there is more supply
and ability to give the vaccine then
there is demand and what's going to have
to be figured out
is will vaccines start to be shifted
from states where there is less demand
to states where there is more
demand of i believe vermont and
massachusetts both at the top with 92
percent of the population wanting the
vaccine
uh is that even possible is it a recipe
for disaster starting to move vaccines
around
instead will will the focus be just on
uh a campaign to make people want the
vaccine yesterday we saw
um joe biden and barack obama
participate in an event talking about
the vaccine encouraging people to get it
i don't know the answer but it seems as
though
today which is the day where everybody
becomes eligible
we are starting to see a slackening of
demand
hopefully full eligibility starting
today
will bring a bunch of new demand and
maybe we can get up to even four million
doses a day
remains to be seen jnj though expected
to come back
online possibly as soon as friday last
week i received an email from a right
wing viewer
saying you know david you cite these
high approval ratings that joe biden
supposedly has
but every time i look at joe biden's
live streams on youtube
it has thousands of dislikes how could
joe biden really be that popular
if he has so many dislikes on youtube
now of course this is very much like the
people who were saying in 2020
during the democratic primary bernie
sanders
is so much more popular than joe biden
on twitter
and he's so much more popular on reddit
how
could bernie sanders possibly lose and
as we quickly learned
in 2020 twitter retweets reddit upvotes
and facebook likes and dislikes and
youtube likes and dislikes
it's not the real world we do actually
have
however real world polling data about
joe biden's presidency so far
and as joe biden is approaching 100 days
in office
his approval at this point is surpassing
george w
bush's bill clinton's george
h w bush's by a tiny bit basically a tie
and by a huge margin donald trump's
approval at this point in time this is
new data from the pew research center
which has joe biden right now at 59
percent
approval at this point in donald trump's
presidency trump was polling
39 it's a 20-point gap
it's not even close and remember that
donald trump never
even hit 50 percent approval for a
single day
during his presidency barack obama was
slightly better than biden at 61
within the margin of error george w bush
was at 55
bill clinton was at just 49. george h.w
bush basically within the margin of
error at 58
and we have uh in in the first april
of ronald reagan's presidency reagan
pulled the highest
at 67 percent how could this be
how could joe biden be polling so well
despite
again dislikes on his youtube live
streams
because the internet is not real life
most working people are not taking time
out of their day
to dislike a joe biden live stream on
youtube in order to make biden look bad
they're working and then they're looking
at did he do coveted stimulus
what's going on with vaccination and in
fact when you ask the question
where is the approval coming from it's
coming from the same places as in
february and march joe biden has 72
approval on managing vaccine
distribution joe biden has 55
approval among republicans on vaccine
distribution
biden has stronger approval than trump
in terms of is he behaving in a way
that is appropriate for a president of
the united states to behave
and the 1.9 trillion dollar covet
stimulus package
which every republican in the house and
senate voted against
is popular with two-thirds of the
country
either strongly or somewhat approving
of the covet stimulus that is a big deal
you don't get to 67 percent with just
democrats
and remember that that's not you know
not a single one of these republican
elected officials in the house or in the
senate
voted for the bill now in terms of the
next few months
if the vaccine rollout continues
if cases resume a downward trend if
things go the way that the highly
vaccinated countries like israel
and the uk are seeing things go cases
plunging deaths plunging things opening
the this could actually turn around for
joe biden
for the worse and you might be saying
well hold on if things keep improving
how could it get worse for joe biden and
this is why
republicans and right-wing media have
done one thing i don't want to say
they've done it well
but they've done it successfully from
their point of view
fox news and newsmax and other
right-wing media
in coordination with republican elected
officials have successfully
turned attention to immigration and when
pew
asked people what are the big problems
right now in the united states
the number of americans now saying
immigration illegal immigration is a big
problem
has gone from just 28 percent in june
up to 48 percent this month that's a 20
20 percentage point jump and that is
potentially huge
they realize this is republicans now in
right-wing media
they realize biden is doing well on
covid biden's doing well on vaccines
biden got a popular stimulus bill done
with no republican support
so they are taking the approach of
pointing to something else
the manufactured crisis at the border
and it is actually working so
this is the potential challenge ahead
for joe biden and the truth is that no
matter what he does
republicans will say he's failing on
immigration this is what republicans do
to democrats no matter what democrats do
on guns
republicans say democrats are trying to
take your guns and no matter what
democrats do
on immigration republicans say democrats
are welcoming dangerous illegals into
the country
and this is going to be a test for biden
and we will see what he can do with it
it's sort of a it
it's a problem of biden's own making
it's not an avoidable one but the better
he does on the pandemic
and the more quickly his management of
vaccination
uh helps us get out of the pandemic
the more of an opportunity there is for
people to take their eye
off that ball and to have their
attention focused on whatever else
republicans are pointing to and right
now that's illegal immigration they have
nothing else that's even remotely policy
oriented
of course they're lying about what's
going on as we've covered before but it
doesn't matter it's working and we see
it in the polling data
so this will be a challenge for joe
biden the better he does on the pandemic
the more he's going to have to deal with
this
and we know what the right wing playbook
is we saw it with bill clinton
we saw it under barack obama the
playbook is the same one it's an
effective playbook that's why they keep
going back to it
we will have more on this story and this
polling data for you
on the david pakman show instagram page
you can find us
on instagram at david pakman show and
while you are there
find me on instagram at david.pacman
both rapidly approaching 100
000 followers on the instagram platform
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show the degree to
which faux
populist rhetoric and the propagandistic
nature
of tucker carlson's fox news program has
completely bamboozled a huge portion of
the american right-wing and even some on
the left is really an important issue to
be explored
there are even people who are already
talking about tucker carlson for
republican presidential nominee
in 2024 and based on just how easily
people are falling for tucker's nonsense
it does not
bode well for the united states in the
sense that
it's clear tucker is able to put
together propaganda
and disinformation that is really
effective
in the current marketplace of ideas and
ignorance
and a complete absence of thought on the
american right
and one of the reasons that tucker
carlson is so effective
is that he is sort of the
anti-intellectuals
pseudo-intellectual and what i mean by
that is tucker carlson has a way of
talking to people
that don't understand anything or know
anything which makes
him seem like a really smart enlightened
and even borderline
intellectual guy and the reason it works
is that when tucker puts out
some idea about economics sociology
people who watch it have never studied
those areas before they have no frame of
reference for comparison and so
tucker sounds convincing and they fall
for it
whereas a more informed person would
hear tucker and say you know the things
tucker is opining about
are completely outside of his area of
expertise they've already been widely
studied
tucker's ideas are half-baked and
ignorant and we already know
about all of these things tucker is
merely quote asking questions about so
here's one example to really make it a
more tangible for you
this is from a recent tucker episode on
fox news and in this one tucker starts
putting out the idea
that you know changes to societies
are really really bad and it's all
fundamentally rooted in tucker carlson's
anti-immigration
nationalist ideas which he masks as a
populist rhetoric people are falling for
it hook line and sinker
so let's dive in and think through some
of what's being said
if you're over 40 you may have trouble
recognizing your own country it's just
too unfamiliar
now the self-righteous children on
social media don't care to notice this
and when they do
they dismiss it any complaint about
change as bigotry
but it's not bigotry it's human nature
abrupt change causes social chaos always
so there are like four or five different
things there that are pretty nonsensical
but they're all thrown together and
people fall for it
he says people over 40 might not
recognize this country anymore
he says abrupt change causes social
chaos
the reality is that there isn't much
abrupt change
happening of the type that tucker is
describing
it's really common as a trope for the
reactionary right to say
things are changing too quickly and it's
for the worse we're losing control of
what we used to have
which was better and we are quickly on
some kind of ramp to something much
worse
the reality is that the country today is
different than it was in the 90s
which was much different than during the
60s and 70s
which had already changed significantly
from the supposed conservative golden
era of the 1950s
which was already different than the the
sort of pre and during world war
ii era where there were big changes
relative to the time between the two
world wars
which was already different from what
the country looked like before world war
one and then before that you're in the
late 1800s where things were
really different we were pre-car we were
pre-aviation we were in the
industrial revolution things are always
changing
and there's always guys like tucker
screaming
that the change is to quit too quick and
it's bad
and we're quickly going down in flames
and it's ripping apart the fabric of the
country now
it is true that most human societies
uh let me put a different way many human
societies
have failed but for different reasons
and
america may fail and i'm going to get
back to that but tucker's refrain
is a tired old refrain that at this
point is just boring
to anyone who has studied the rise and
fall of societies and civilizations but
we'll get back to that let's look at
another clip
human beings develop customs and habits
and generational expectations
for a reason it's not random continuity
is comforting to people if you eliminate
familiar things overnight
societies fracture populations tend to
explode
we've seen that happen the last
industrial revolution in the end
provoked armed revolutions hundreds of
millions of people died germany got
hitler
eastern europe got stalinism yes we did
wind up with antibiotics in the end
you could think technology for that and
we do but we also got genocide and
atomic bombs
this is absolutely bonkers that this is
so off the wall
that it's actually hard to even know how
how to start picking it apart because it
just makes no sense
tucker's throwing things together there
that are barely related and here's the
thing
and this goes back to what i said at the
beginning of the segment
there are lots of people watching tucker
who simply have never thought about
these topics in these terms
it's similar to when a college freshman
that has never been exposed to any
economics goes to micro101
and suddenly they are neoclassical
economics believers they believe that
neoclassical
standard economics is that it's all
there is that it's right that's it
then though you start to learn about
other economic theory
you read some behavioral economics you
read some marks
you get a wider view and then you come
to realize well the first thing i heard
isn't always or necessarily correct
on this issue you would be vaccinated
for lack of a better term
against tucker's nonsense if you had
previously read some of this stuff for
example
the work of jared diamond this is not
dense academic stuff
jared diamond's work on why societies
fail or succeed
is very accessible and if you were
familiar with that
just that and of course there's dozens
hundreds of other things
that would have insulated you where you
would hear tucker say this you would say
this guy has no idea what he's talking
about
the arguments he's making are not based
in history historical fact they're not
based in anything other than tucker's
wishes as to what he wants the united
states to look like this is just one
example
but you would then not be falling for
just any old thing
tucker says about societal change and
what hurts or helps occult culture you
would be protected because you would
have some
knowledge from actual experts on this
issue let's watch a little more of the
clip
there's a lesson here if you're going to
change things go slowly
choose the incremental over the
immediate explain yourself
as you do it reassure people acknowledge
the reality of evolutionary biology it
is real
human beings are not born to be machine
components you can't just
bang out improved versions of your
citizens on a 3d printer
people in real life are complicated and
stubborn and hard to control
even the most open-minded ones get jumpy
when suddenly everything's different
the truth is just about everything is
changing incrementally it's not really
changing rapidly i mean
you know sociologist tucker carlson is
feeding you drivel here
look at health care look at how slowly
it has changed
it took basically 20 years to get the
affordable care act remember
the affordable care act under a
different name and put together by
different people
was first floated in the early 90s it
took basically 20 years to get that
and that is a relatively modest change
to the system look at societal views on
gay marriage which shifted
so slowly over decades legalization
in a few states then eventually full
legalization in 2015 we are only now
getting to the point where more than
half the country supports gay marriage
thanks to some more republicans getting
on on board so
the change has been slow by modern
standards
it is true that humanity in the last 500
years has changed very quickly
compared to the slow evolution of homo
sapiens over millions of years but
tucker's not talking about that in a
global sense
he's talking about cultural norms in the
united states
here's the last piece of the segment
obviously and you'd think it would be
obvious
wise leaders would know that intuitively
if you're going to have relentless
technological change
and apparently we are you cannot inflict
relentless social change
and expect your society to survive
things will fall apart if you do that
that's guaranteed
yet that is exactly what our leaders are
currently doing they're changing
everything
whether we like it or not a new language
new values new biology new curricula
new social mores and hiring standards
and body types
a brand new national population okay so
you know that this is the type of rant
that leads conservatism
into the ideology of preserve society as
it is
merely because change is scary and we
assume bad
and short of that tucker says the new
technology is mostly good but don't
change society along with it and that
that also makes no sense anybody who has
read about technological change and here
again very accessible i'm going off the
top of my head look at the work of
max tegmark a look at the work of bill
bryson
and you know i'm kind of blanking here
but there's so much accessible stuff on
this issue
how could you have the technology
technological
acceleration that tucker seems to say is
good but have no societal change either
that also
is completely a-historical in fact i
just finished reading
cal newport's new book a world without
email
where he talks about how because of
email a lot of jobs have become
30 40 50 60 just
managing an email inbox rather than
doing
the work that's sort of core to what you
do but one of the interesting things
that cal newport talks about is that
email
wasn't just you have work and office
culture
and then income's email and now you have
the same work in office culture
plus email it doesn't work that way
email
actually changed in significant ways
over a period of 30 years work culture
and office culture and the nature of
work
you can't have just you drop in a
technological change and nothing
changes but tucker wants you to believe
the change is out of control
and it's for the worst and it could be
the downfall of society and this is what
people have been saying for hundreds of
years in the us
the industrial revolution was going to
be it um
you know cars uh airplanes
uh women voting you know if whatever
example you want to find
you can find it and it's really one of
the best examples
this clip we looked at of what tucker
does so well
but it only works effectively on an
ignorant audience that has no frame of
reference
on these issues there's another new
problem
for the republican party which is that
college educated
voters are abandoning the party quite
quickly
to a degree that i didn't even realize
check out this report from msnbc about
recent polling
welcome back data download time we've
talked a lot here about how the two
political parties are
changing and now there are new warning
signs for the republicans
in that realignment in the first quarter
of this year gallup found that democrats
have a nine-point edge
in party identification it's the largest
gap gallups recorded
in a decade and now we've seen this
before
and it hasn't always stuck that said
data from the pew research center shows
that the shift of college-educated
voters
from red to blue could indeed have
long-term
consequences and here's why at the
beginning of this century republicans
held an 11-point edge
among this group of voters by the time
barack obama was president the figures
had flipped
and it became a narrow four-point edge
for the democrat then along came
president trump
and as he was winding down democrats had
a whopping 13-point lead among this
group of voters
now here's why this matters because
republicans have long counted on
the high turnout rates of
college-educated suburban voters
especially during midterm and special
elections
and yet in 2018 64 of people with a
bachelor's degree
went to the polls and watch this that
compares with 52 percent of those with
just some college or an associate's
degree it's 39
among those high school or less and it's
only 20 percent for those
without a high school diploma all of
this could spell trouble for republicans
if they are losing the most reliable
voters to democrats we actually may have
seen that already
in georgia and in a statewide election
in wisconsin when more and more people
are getting college degrees
how do you win when you have a 13 point
deficit among the college educated
voters or to put it another way
college educated people are more likely
to vote
and increasingly more people are going
to college and
increasingly those people are going to
vote for democrats that's a recipe for
disaster for the republican party
now a common sense reaction if you're
the republican party
would be well let's figure out why
college-educated voters are abandoning
us and let's fix that issue
but that's not the approach of the
republican party the republican approach
instead has been let's
trash going to college as liberal
nonsense
so maybe fewer people will go and
meanwhile let's make it harder to vote
in areas we've identified as being more
democratic leaning
and that strategy it can work in theory
at least in the short run it can also
fail
arguably it failed in 2020 in places
like georgia
but i don't see how the strategy works
long term this is a stunning trend and
as chuck todd pointed out in that
segment
the republican party used to lead among
college-educated voters
then in the obama era obama was like
plus four among educate college-educated
voters
now democrats are plus 13. some of you
may be surprised
that college-educated voters ever voted
for republicans but remember that there
was a time when relatively fewer people
went to college
those that did made more money therefore
they paid more in taxes
and arguably they would develop some
animosity
uh to the party of higher taxes and they
shifted to the right
since then though the republican party
although it is anti-tax has become also
a lot of other crazy things
anti-science anti-life anti-common sense
and the tax thing
uh no longer seems to be the controlling
factor you can put it a different way
also
the republican party has gone so far off
the deep end that they are even starting
to lose the people who want low taxes
and since ronald reagan as i've told you
many times the republican party has been
creating this environment in which
someone like trump can win
they've done it relatively successfully
winning a bunch of elections but when
trump actually came in he blew
everything up and maybe it was too far
they now have a policy where paul they
have a party
where policy essentially doesn't matter
it's just rhetoric
it's owning the libs it's you know
arguing that you want to bring guns
under the house floor
and as a result they lost the house in
2018 they lost the senate in 2020
they lost the white house in 2020 so
they are left with almost nothing
that is the vacuum into which fox and
tucker
and newsmax and these types jim jordan
marjorie taylor green
they can fill the void with their
outrageous rhetoric
which further radicalizes the party but
it's not it's not dealing with policy
can they turn it around sure they can i
mean you know i
i've looked at deeper and more detailed
opinion surveys trying to figure out
what is it that would bring
college-educated voters back to the
republican party
if the country became more religious
would that do it
um unclear unclear and remember that the
country
is becoming less religious uh on issues
the country is also moving left
you know abortion being legal in most
cases has the
biggest support it's had since roe v
wade i mentioned earlier
gay marriage being legal has more
support today than at any day in
american history
inequality being too high and being bad
for the country
is something that more people today
agree with than at any time
in the past so on the religiosity thing
things aren't turning back to the right
on the issues things aren't turning to
the right this is why
the republican party has adopted a
strategy of voter suppression
trying to steal elections rather than to
win them and when you see this polling
it does make sense it does make if you
realize we can't seem to win on issues
the issues we used to win on are
increasingly going against
us in that sense you would try to just
win in other ways and that's exactly
what they're doing
we'll take a quick break we have much
more after this
find me this is very exciting i've not
been this excited about a new platform
in a long time
find me on bitclout where we have
pacmancoin i know it sounds nuts but
it's very interesting
go to davidpakman.combitclout that's bit
clout at minimum follow me there we're
going to have some very interesting
things there
uh but you're if you're in that space i
think you'll find the platform really
interesting quick break
right back after this you can follow us
on facebook at facebook.com
davidpakmanshow and on twitter at
davidpakmanshow
and if you want to reach me directly no
trolling allowed
follow me on twitter at deephackman hope
to
hear from you soon so i don't really
even know what to make of this but
radical deranged delusional fantasy
world
religious televangelist pat robertson of
course known from the 700 club which has
been around for decades at this point
he did a mostly accurate
and pretty sober and precise assessment
of police killings including
specifically
of the killing in minnesota of dante
wright
it's almost i'm kind of joking here it's
almost like pat robertson became woke
and i'm joking because i don't actually
use that term but check out this video
pat robertson's co-host pointing out
the entire taser versus gun confusion
that's being
claimed is a terrible explanation for
the officer involved in the shooting
tasers and guns are kept on opposite
sides of police utility belts
guns and tasers feel totally different
and then pat robertson i venture to say
here
delivers an impassioned statement about
the issue
facing our country check this out
talking about george floyd and derek
chauvin the dante right shooting
police and more i don't know it's pat
robertson take a look
also i want to say you know i i think a
lot of people are
thinking like i was that both gun
both the gun and the taser would be put
on your dominant side but it's not that
way
they have to cross over the hill in a
different direction so you actually have
to reach across yourself do you feel the
difference
yeah it's definitely there's just this
harrison
as i say they're not making tasers in
this yellow color anymore
they're making a they're in black
they're making them yellow now how she
made the difference when she shot that
poor guy to death
saying this is what i thought this is
i thought was my taser and and if you
can't tell the difference
within the field of those things it's
crazy anyhow
she deserves but i you know i
am pro-police folks i think we need the
police we need
their service and they do a good job but
if they don't stop this onslaught they
cannot do this
you know the the police in virginia
picked up a
a lieutenant in the army and began to
give him trouble
and our our state police are highly
trained
but why they don't stop this and this
thing is going on in minnesota but the
derrick shelby
i mean they ought to put him under the
jail he has caused so much
trouble by kneeling on the the death of
george floyd
he's just coming on his neck it's just
terrible what's happening
and the police why don't they open their
eyes to what the public relations
are they've got to stop this stuff so
there is pat robertson
at the age of 91 years coming across
a good take somehow it happened now
you know okay some of what pat robertson
is saying seems to be
that lots of this stuff just makes
police look bad
versus it's actually bad that i
understand that maybe there's an aspect
of that here
i've never seen anything like this from
pat robertson now this doesn't make pat
robertson
a progressive beacon of hope hope uh but
but um as he pointed out
um even pat robertson seems to realize
that the situation
in the country has become completely
absurd
there's an opposite interpretation as
well
uh if pat robertson is actually able to
see
this situation for what it is doesn't it
make it more likely
that he realized all of realizes all of
the other stuff he's saying is bogus but
he says it anyway in order to get
donations or clicks or ratings or
to placate his right-wing religious
audience i don't know
the other thing is there are some
instances in pat robertson's past where
he'll say something kind of logical
and then there will be blowback and then
he'll just backtrack a week later i
think this happened once with with
cannabis legalization where he said
something that was pretty pretty logical
his audience went nuts and next thing we
knew he had basically recanted his view
but i do think that the one may be
consistent takeaway
is that there are lots of people who
when they're able to separate themselves
from their partisanship and their
tribalism they realize
at a deep gut level what's going on with
guns
and or with police shootings is not okay
they they get it
then very often after they have the gut
reaction they turn on fox news
or whatever and they realize oh there's
partisan talking points i have to get in
line with but there's like this brief
moment of clarity that they seem to have
then the nra comes in and they say no no
no this is evidence we need more guns
uh police should have more guns and
people should have more guns and they
should be easier to buy
and then they mostly fall in line but
many of these people i think for a
moment get it
anyway no need to now
start praising pat robertson more than
he deserves but it's an interesting
segment
certainly not something i was expecting
to see and maybe there's like some
glimmer of hope here
that there's maybe an opportunity to get
consensus on the issue of guns and
police
if we can separate people from their
reflexive partisan reactions and that's
not easy
there's a reason that if you go back to
the sandy hook shooting
uh which was what was that 2012 it's
it's
insane that it's been almost a decade if
so you go back to the sandy hook
shooting
and you had an 88 to 90 uh uh approval
rating
from the country saying we need 100
universal background checks
it didn't happen even with that level of
agreement it didn't happen and we have
almost nothing in this country
where you have 88 to 90 agreement but
people had the gut reaction wait a
second
there are some gun transactions where
you don't need a background check
that doesn't make sense at a fundamental
level then in came the nra
in came the republican politicians and
nothing got done
so maybe the takeaway here is not pat
robertson beacon of woke
or beacon of hope or whatever uh but
that there's an opportunity there
brief as it may be where there may be
more agreement on these issues than it
sometimes seems
hey this is really interesting news out
of texas uh actor matthew mcconaughey
or mcconaughey as some people like to
say is polling 12 points ahead of
republican texas governor greg abbott
he's not running if your reaction was i
didn't know that
he was running he's not this is a new
poll from the dallas morning
news and the university of texas tyler
it's based on 1100 registered voters
30 democrats 37 republicans
33 percent who are neither 45 percent of
voters
say they would support matthew
mcconaughey over greg
abbott if matthew mcconaughey were to
run for governor
33 said they'd support abbott over
mcconaughey
22 say they would vote for someone else
or aren't really sure
this is interesting because mcconaughey
has actually kind of teased and alluded
to maybe running
in the state of texas he is not
confirmed
he told cnbc last month he is not joking
he said quote i'm not
teasing the idea i'm actually looking at
the idea and giving it serious
consideration
i have a new chapter for myself
personally in my life i believe it's
some sort of leadership role i don't
know what the role is i don't know my
category
we've been talking about the why of
leadership and even
i would say we need some more good
leaders
this would be fascinating so
there's two parts to this i don't know
how much this says about matthew
mcconaughey specifically
uh what i mean by that is greg abbott
has so mismanaged almost everything i
mean the pandemic
uh the power outage and grid electrical
grid situation
he's a complete and total clown who
doesn't seem to care much about the
health or safety or welfare of people in
texas
it's possible a random school teacher
with no name recognition
would maybe do okay against greg abbott
so part of it is we have to figure out
how much of it is
matthew mcconaughey specifically uh but
then you add in the fact that
if you look at matthew mcconaughey over
the last 12 to 18 months i've been
seeing him doing more and more
conversations and interviews
with people in the political space he
does actually seem interested he seems
to be taking this seriously i don't know
the guy's politics i have no idea
whether
uh he's a democrat or a republican i
don't know anything about him what i do
know though
is that he at least doesn't seem like a
radical right winger if he is a
centrist or further left and if without
even announcing a candidacy he is doing
this well
in texas what we saw in 2020 in texas
the tightening in texas for trump uh
in in his re-election campaign uh which
ultimately didn't end up being that
close but it was
could it could have been a much much
bigger uh margin for donald trump
this could signal significant changes in
the state of texas
and uh we are all we can do is continue
to follow it we've been talking about it
before
georgia and texas have been the ones
that we've been watching relatively
closely
very interesting and we're going to keep
a close eye on that we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p
i can't tell fully if this voicemail
is anti-transgender or sort of neutral
or what the caller is exactly talking
about so i want to play it
and listen to it together with you let's
see if we can figure this out
hi david my name is ashley um i wanted
to talk about the
transgenders i think it doesn't take a
genius to realize
that when you put a bunch of people who
are from different backgrounds and
different ethnicities together
you're going to end up with some people
that are kind of confusing
so i'm i'm noticing the constant up
speak
that's not really bothering me it's more
you know
the transgenders it's already kind of
weird
i don't necessarily think it's about
gender i just think it's like
you just have different looking people
that you're not used to seeing
and i guess this draws like a lot of
conclusions but i don't think
i don't think it takes a genius to
figure out that
when you're born a woman with a vagina
that means you're a woman for life and
that when you're a
man when you're born with a penis
you're a dude for life i don't think it
takes a genius
okay so it's seeming anti-trans right to
figure that out
and if there's some weird complications
it's probably because of the cultural
difference
and i just think this is complete what
what is comp what does complication mean
i don't even know what th what they're
saying
well [ __ ] and these people are really
ignorant
which people that's a weird voicemail
right
help me parse that out and figure out
what what it's all about i don't really
i don't really understand what that's
what's going on there
we have a great it doesn't sound good
though let me put it that way it doesn't
sound particularly enlightened or
sensitive
um we have a great bonus show for you
today we will be talking about the
america first caucus which lasted one
day
it involves marjorie taylor green and it
lasted one day
massachusetts also doing some very
interesting new climate law
that if it all goes as planned
we'll zero out carbon pollution for the
state
very very aggressive and forward-looking
and we will also look at what seems to
be
uh senate democrats settling on a 25
corporate tax rate for joe biden's
changes to the tax plan remember
it was 35 percent previously trump
dropped it to 21.
joe biden was looking at raising to 28
and it looks as though senate democrats
are okay with 25
what i want to talk about is whether
this even matters and some of you who
have heard me talk about the corporate
tax rate before probably already know
where where i'm going that's on today's
bonus show okay get
instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at
joinpacman.com we have a coupon code the
coupon code is
better21 and very exciting
follow me on bitcloud i
rarely am excited about new platforms
i'm very excited about this one i spent
the weekend
checking it out uh go to davidpakman.com
bitclout c-l-o-u-t
follow me there at minimum check out how
it works
i'll have more about it later in the
week